you got a nice crown for that victory
too thanks
you could buy those cosmetics you don't
like to use yeah i'm okay you could buy
a color
no i'm already probably some fleshier
colors you could be no
i just i like this one for some reason
it really speaks to me am i in the very
middle
i'm on the front left corner i think i'm
on i'm if that's me in the
no i'm not that's not me next to you all
right you're off to my left
out of my way oh my god screw this
everyone just go
jesus i am not gonna fight people on the
tubes yes
yes i made it out of my way out of the
way i'm the best
in a long time i made that cleanly yeah
i'm in the lead group boys dreams are
coming true oh my god i'm in a massive
stampede of [ __ ]
it happens happens oh my god where is
everyone going oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh no are you kidding me no
no no no i got bald into oblivion i
didn't know that could happen
i warned you about that exact scenario
other guy with the weird
oh my gosh i got i got
i got this bone that's fine i believe a
hard
i see my path i think i'm just gonna
make it
36th oh my god okay
oh my god oh yes good good you got first
i think so i was me and one other guy
that were right there hell yeah man this
is bodes well for your future
okay all right i can do i'm wearing a
gig yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah levels like
this all day i will
i'm not gonna go through the middle at
that one part where i always think i can
do it yeah
right there in the middle i can't do it
it's like not even
worth it i think it would be really
funny if we got to the end and just made
a dildo wall on the last platform just
about why does finishing first get me in
the [ __ ] back
clearly you are good okay why
oh my god oh my god else whipped me
oh my god well at least i'm here yes
yeah oh no no no no
yes no no oh my god get out of the way
you dumb piece of [ __ ]
god damn it everyone's trying to do the
center
okay yeah we're fine we're fine we're
fine oh god there's a pigeon in front of
me
i hate pigeons oh my god oh my god what
the hell
what the hell did you just get eated
i wouldn't get back up my character
didn't get back up
hey did you see those people get sucked
out from under me yes i did
yes i did oh my god oh my god bad timing
good timing
oh that's a big herd coming okay i'm
just gonna get across the finish line
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
oh my god oh my god one of the [ __ ]
got hit and it baseballed me into the
[ __ ] outfield uh-huh
uh-huh mark did you make it i made it
barely i i just
i'm on a [ __ ] parade i don't know what
that means
[Music]
i don't know you're honest are you the
one doing the [ __ ]
what is this oh this one okay so you
want to stay the edges and use the
wedges as a little safety cover
edge wedge got it how many fruit are we
dodging a lot
a lot very much oh
why are you morons in front of me being
idiots
all right mark i'm coming in okay coming
in behind you okay gotcha this is
please don't fall down and ruin
everything for me oh no
watermelon oh my god banana oh my god
you know your fruit
oh my god mangoes one's a mango one's
not an apple it's actually a mango
oh my god oh my god oh my god let me
through please please let me through
i'm gonna make it are we all out
yeah all right well i'll exit then what
is block party oh that one looks
fun it is fun i wish it happened more
yeah there's
there's so many things that i've never
done what the hell which one's block
party
someone where the walls come up and you
gotta go through the hole in the wall oh
yeah yeah okay
now it seems fun okay and exit don't
forget to jump on that blue ramp mark
you're gonna need to remind me i'm not
gonna remember
near the end when you're about to lose
and okay when about to
lose definitely do the thing
oh god get off me your [ __ ] unicorns
oh my god i'm in first place
okay where do i jump where do i jump
this is this one the big blue ramp the
big blue ridge
no not like this oh my god i'm about to
get
third place no way whoa you almost got
yes hey you got like fifth place mark
like yeah
speed demons out here all done i don't
know how to tell you this but i'm pretty
good
i'm pretty good oh no oh got the balls
and we're facing the wrong way we're
always doing that i think we have a
pigeon on our team though that bodes
well
come on pigeon
no okay that didn't really work the way
i hoped it would no
no okay no yellow [ __ ]
there we go all right i got one in we
got one solidly in
yeah we got three in right now i'm just
gonna play defense that's what i'm gonna
do
okay i got one solidly back in oh oh
jesus this ball
is on fire how did that go so high in
the air
i don't know all right all right blue's
in a little bit of peril we might be
able to steal one here from the middle
trying to be a
douche we don't have a lot of defense
and a lot of people are trying to bone
us at the moment
but we're okay yeah we need to stay like
an either we're in the process of
stealing like
two or three all right look you little
[ __ ] unicorn
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh no no no i'm the problem i'm the part
of the problem
i was part of the prophet oh no i was
part of the problem
are we are we are we fine we're fine one
ball solidly and one about to be stolen
oh my god i'm being grabbed by a hot dog
now i'm grabbing a [ __ ]
five seconds where that's the end wait
wait screw yellow screw yellow just
don't you don't get any points
yeah red red balloons we're good red's
good red's good oh my god you're all
all right got [ __ ] by a hot dog but
honestly it wasn't that bad i would do
it again
circle really really give us a different
game come on we saw those fun games that
we didn't get to play
i know they tease you with the good
stuff and then they make you play
fortnite over and over again
oh my god we have an oven mitt on our
team
i know it's a pineapple but it like it
looks like an oven mitt and i can't
unsee that
now i can't either it does look like an
oven mitt push
push boys oh my god oh my god we're in
very last
push we need someone to go [ __ ] all
right we're pushing
well if we can just get around this
absolutely yeah yeah yeah go go expertly
done all right
go go go go go go oh no
yeah yeah we can go oh my god that's the
momentum
we need some serious momentum with the
jump dives yes hit him
hit him hit him oh my god no no no no no
no oh go
get it over there okay you got it yeah
yeah
yeah it's fine it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine it's funny oh it's not
sacrifice yourself why did we push it
directly
into them all we had to do was not go
right with it
i think there should be a rule no two
ball ones
in the same round this is not fun it's
not fair there's so many other game
modes that i know exist
and we haven't played them oh now
they're getting to do the block party
okay and the one that i can't leave that
we got eliminated from
okay this is the jumpy one this is the
one you jump on
yumpy jumpy and i'm good i'm in the very
back
i'm in the pack of [ __ ] outside life
oh perfect navigation
also too man me also do my wide
left baby why is this triceratops faster
than me
because he's better than you longer legs
damn it hey what's
yeah i do you know i do man always oh
god oh god
what is happening what is happening what
is happening potentially right
[Laughter]
i think mark's losing his actual [ __ ]
over there first what happened
did you not finish no i made it
i made it from second to like 14th or
something
why what did you do i got stuck in
between
the second and third ring i kept getting
up and it knocked me back over like it
was like
and then a ball hit me and then another
ball hit me
and then the crowd came it was just like
oh god damn it again oh man remember all
those fun game modes
oh no because we've never tried them oh
yeah yeah no i love this one i'm gonna
try doing the thing where i don't
memorize at all i'm just gonna go where
the crowd goes
bold strategies
oh you like that minions movie that's
what that's what those are that's what
those fellows say right
okay apple watermelon actually
mango apparently apple
no that's far away oh i can't move
oh my god everyone
okay all is well orange cherry grape
grape cherry orange orange
which one which one which one which one
which one okay
oh my god there's a lot of us on here
qualified right we're done hey yay i
actually
did memorize it so oh yeah did or didn't
i didn't i didn't memorize where the
apple thing or mango apple
banana where's my guy all the way in the
bottom right away from everyone
what's wrong with me could we maybe see
a different game mode no way
tails slime
yikes i don't think back in the middle
of attack we gotta work for this
oh my god they won't even let me get up
oh okay okay okay okay
oh okay me i hate people
god great well having a huge crowd of
idiots in front of you does block the
balls from crushing you on this one
section
oh god stop oh my god you suck
no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass ding dong oh my god did you
just grab me you [ __ ]
you've made an enemy for life
the top
if you see that ninja dude grab him the
one in first the one who stole
every bit of my glory oh i'm grabbing a
god i'm grabbing him
grab him he's mine grab him
i got oh jerk
i'm gonna report him if any developers
are watching
me in my stream which i assume you are
because i'm amazing find
the person who was that ninja and i want
you to ban them
i am calling this right now because i
know i have influence and power
and i'm going to use it what if we just
banned literally everyone that's not us
for the game let me know
let's do that developers you know who i
am hey call me
dm me on twitter i don't give up my
phone number oh it's tiptoe
oh wow i haven't played this one you
know they disable some maps or something
because i swear we're just not seeing
some of them at all
i was hoping for this uh guys are you
guys ready for some awesomeness
shloop oh well that was actually right
all right
wow wade's got the okay watch out for
this pigeon he's the a-hole oh my god oh
my god
oh man oh my god you also
you all suck oh everyone sucks turns out
shockingly everyone sucks oh
okay
ah [ __ ] i thought that was good it was
not good good job wade
you got this oh no oh no knock some of
them off knock many of them off i'm
going for it
it's me no
oh bob did you not make it no it's
almost like that one is an actually
random chance and it's just waiting
and it's such a fair fair game it's
waiting and not being knocked off or
grabbed
oh god i wonder if i hope it's the tail
one
stop you i'm gonna stop you right there
i hope i can only hope
oh it's falling out in there a full
mountain okay i see that you can do it
friends
you got it you gotta wave the [ __ ]
hot dog i'm gonna
smother my face into your hot dog
[ __ ] that's weird
yeah sorry it's a little strange weird
kinks
that's not really smash your face into
this for me so i don't have to i'm gonna
grab this guy
okay i got him go wait watch out oh come
on come on wade
you can do it get him and stuff
go go buddy
mark that's not a good place to be ah
he's fine i didn't expect to win
i'm gonna get this speed boost damn it i
got your strategy
ah it didn't wait don't let the hot dog
win
i've got the middleware you're about to
get
like shredded i was trying to get the
boost on hot dog one
hey that's okay the hot dog that
happened to have spawned five feet in
front of me one by five feet i can't
imagine why
hmm i tried to grab them it just didn't
work and then i got obliterated by a
ball
where am i out the back oh i'm very bad
dead middle
oh yeah very back all right guys let's
do this i guess
oh this idiot wasn't even moving
oh everyone in front of me just jumped
each other off so
good for them why are you going this way
why would you do this seems incredibly
stupid
all right i'll bite okay we're gonna go
with the [ __ ] team this time
oh no get to the middle get to the front
get to the middle get to the front
let me throw it let me through oh my god
my path is clear i see my path i'm the
first one
yes [ __ ] who touched me who
who touched me who touched me who
touched me
mark i can't tell if this is you there's
a whole heart of you this time here
barely god barely qualified
bear who finished first me finished well
done yeah yeah good job where did you
make it
no i got [ __ ] oh you want us to back
out
no no no no i want you to win oh um
that's a lot of pressure
let me guess tiptoe oh hey i haven't
played this team to get completely
jinxed or eliminated what wait what
happens what's that what is that what
how what is this what oh so someone is
like purple glowy
in the middle don't let them touch you
oh no this is like
your goal is to not be like infected
oh okay it's like dodge the infection
that's spreading
oh god okay well don't grab me team
mates
why would you grab me what team are you
my son i'm blue
i'm assuming this is you running in
circles on the ground by the purple ramp
no maybe i don't know which the person
who's infected on our end over
on my end over here doesn't seem to be
able to get anyone so this is kind of a
low
kind of a low threat i'm watching one of
the blue teammates try to infect more
blue
that's not how that works oh my god
people don't that's a yike for me
dog uh okay you don't even come and
spread it to the
cooties get infected oh my god cooties
down in the trench
oh god oh my god oh god our teammates
need to really
go oh my god correct oh no i'm about to
get cooties
why no cooties for me please no cooties
no cooties
no cooties oh my god no cooties my god
goodies
i'm cootied i've got cooties hello i got
one come here
i got one do i have to grab the tools oh
do i have to grab them
yeah you have to grab them but i didn't
know why is there a blue
going after other blues what is wrong
with you
my god i didn't know you had to grab
guys
were you just bumping into people i mean
i got infected way
late but i thought i thought if you just
bump into them you know
oh they got block part yeah that's the
third time today
that block party has been the thing
after we're all out how
how am i supposed to know these things
guys how do i know these things
it didn't say in the instructions why
don't you know stuff what are you doing
i've never it didn't say in the
instructions it said just
last one to get jinxed
you unbelievable dumb you didn't say in
the instructions
it didn't say can i exit i can read
faster than
any one of you any one of you
yeah mark's read six books since we went
live
the middle front baby well not not as
little as you i guess
we've got this boys
get out of my way oh my god that's not
gonna work for me
yes i am the champion oh just get out of
my way
oh my god oh no the best thing happened
okay okay hey how's it going
oh my god oh no no no no
there's a jump there's a jump at the
bottom of this there's a jump there's a
jump
hey i beat wade hey mark made it in
look at us finisher
oh no do you see this pink and yellow
striped one who can't get through the
gate
they keep going oh they gave him oh no
back and forth back and forth i don't
know what to do
i have totally been that person
block party something new nope garbage
tiptoe soccer it's going to be five
rounds of tiptoe let's do this
mark what have we learned wait for the
right door don't
guess no no i can't be it no well
someone has to go first so i'm happy
with that being you i guess okay
all right i got this guys don't worry
i'm i'm out i'm gonna have to win it
bold bold makes the wins
oh god i'm in the back this is good it's
intentionally
actually that's not that's not bad it's
not bad not for this one all right let's
see let's see
i'm going to get lucky you're going to
get lucky right now oh there's wait
there's so many openable doors wait what
less open each round oh i was already
there it's not just
one per level oh hey we're all right on
each other please don't guys
oh my god oh that's not the one
that's not the one oh [ __ ] oh no why am
i leading the way fine it's fine
oh no i'm at the back of the pack it's
not fine i almost leaped off the
over the edge come on come on give me
the one be the one be the one be the one
be the one
no no no no no okay can only be one of
these
it's dead
oh my god i think i was just barely
going to make it in we made it
oh last one i think i was
yeah i think it was literally the last
one all right that was fun that's good
hey
waiting for other people to go first
really worked really
it really was right i did make a bold
claim at one time that got me
uh in first so that was that was good
yay oh my god roll out i really messed
this one up last time
yeah watch this [ __ ] up again i'm going
to lose one time we got to play i think
we all died really fast
yeah i've not died on this one yet but
that's probably a
bad thing to say okay
mark how you doing i'm good man oh god
if you go i'm out
oh there's a huge gap there i see i see
what your concern is about
it's not the thing no it's not reality
this isn't real i
am i'm i'm dreaming you're all right
mark i'm fine
did you really die instantly hey
i for some reason i i forgot that you
can slide
off of things so you just like let it
kick you off slowly
no i left uh literally off the edge and
tried to land on a vertical
platform before it was even up i didn't
need to go
i could have waited and i didn't you
just
gave it up huh i uh you know i am block
party
ah
like someone just kicked him in the
kidney all right wade the key to this
one
is hugging your friends all right so you
just come here we just give each other
hugs
we'll be safe cool
no we just give each other strong hugs
and we'll be so safe oh see how great we
are
you see how safe we are wait wait give
me a hug come here baby
oh hat give me your baby oh come here
come on hug hug daddy wait is this the
[ __ ] buddy
please come on see the key
the key is the hugs the hugs will keep
us safe see how safe we are
why do you think i ran so aggressively
what are you doing i don't know dying
horribly here see give each other a
little hug i give you a back hug
i love back hugs oh oh oh oh oh this is
nice oh
okay everyone group scoop the [ __ ] away
oh god first of all
hugs oh wait oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait
oh okay all right hug me no please
hug
you know you know i've got the scoops
don't you want to hang out with the one
who's got the
[ __ ] oh god oh my god
okay wait do you want to hug do you need
a hug
i just want to stand you need a stress
relief hug
oh where you at buddy i glitched into
the floor and died
oh that sounds like you really needed a
hug
this one looks really fun guys mark this
one's so fun
yep
oh hug me fake mark
i i'm there with you in spirit hang on i
gotta i gotta go discipline i gotta
discipline my chat real quick
you think no hang on you think
you you you you think
that this makes you better than me
you're wrong i
was seeing so far into the future
that i was two steps ahead of everyone
that i anticipated a move i needed to
make before it happened
because that's how intelligent and big
brain i am cease you're yammering
i am the streamer now i am the one
who sees into the future it's me
i love you never you
hi i'm back i did now hey
bob good job i did it oh no oh boy
it's uh okay i'm in a slow play i'm
gonna use my stratagem
oh i just i have to peek
sorry
oh good moves though oh
oh nice oh no oh got it back
oh no oh
well that wasn't oh who got it what the
hell
all right all right guy number seven hot
some hot action some hot action
spicy spicy hot ah the toucan
the toucan who can hide
got to the top and was like oh yes hey
yes
yes yeah almost
[ __ ] that you can't oh no yes maybe take
the shot
no no no no no i thought someone else
had it excellent excellent
excellent routes excellent excellent
routes the smoothest pathing in the game
oh cut the corner excellent routing
excellent excellent routing
what oh get the nasty thing get the
fleshy volcano monster
get the 1990s dinosaur
get yes yes excellent
yes yes
oh that's my first win ever ever
ever full skill baby all skill all skill
all day long
i almost vomited up my lungs oh i almost
ate it yeah wait side your turn yeah
i've seen your path it's time
it's time really it's my time now
now is the time you guys really believe
in me we don't just believe in you
i've bet a lot of money in vegas on you
like
a lot of money you could have just given
me that money no you were never to get
any of the money i've just bet money on
you
so if you win i win a lot of money and
you get the satisfaction of victory but
if you lose
i am going to steal your kneecaps oh
that doesn't sound good they're pretty
worn out and bad but if you want them
like that's fair that's fair trade
fair why suddenly names uh on the screen
now
if you left trigger you can turn the
monitor oh my god yeah it was just like
fall guy
[Music]
hey god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god thank you
okay oh don't touch me oh someone got
launched perfectly that they're very
happy about that probably
oh okay okay okay
oh god yes yes yes beautiful beautiful
run
beautiful ride
cheeseburger person oh my god stupid
idiots are going up the middle path
what a bunch of why am i under the
ground what happened to me there
what happened to you i don't know i was
just the dream
run wade come with me be with me wade
how do you [ __ ] the solid second
place finish here
all right i'm uh also coming here excuse
me mark come here what's happening today
bud
hold me oh not you hold me i'm holding
you
all right oh i apparently shove you into
the finish line what are you doing
oh my god wait get off come on wait come
on
i'm dancing give me a hug oh yeah all
right guys maybe maybe get in
maybe okay
for some reason i didn't know there was
a baby jump in this game i went to jump
one of the platforms
and just my my poor kneecaps that mark's
gonna take
just didn't work i'm only gonna take
your kneecaps if you don't win
that's the only thing so win well i did
how many do you have to win not to win
the whole you have to win the whole
thing as long as you don't get any team
games
i feel pretty good hey a team game oh it
does say ground
it does say grab don't grab your own
team if you're infected you [ __ ]
maybe maybe it's a strategy to get
infected early so you can start
interacting with play aggressive
yeah maybe we should do that let's try
that i'm gonna try that
okay grab me okay i've been grabbed i'm
gonna go start infecting right away
and you're getting grabbed i grabbed one
good work good work nice
nice nice another where we are and we
are in the lead excellent excellent this
is excellent
i'm gonna get really dizzy here oh
grabbed okay get him
interesting interesting strategies we
have a we have a teammate hot dog
chilling okay i've grabbed like four
people already
got one and there we go oh he fell down
get him
get him how's he not grabbed
how has he not been grabbed oh my god
get over here
get over here he's infected he's
infected we got one here
there's one on the other side of this
ramp where
oh my god oh my god no
wade this isn't my game mode is garbage
wait wait
that wasn't my fault all right all of
all of my money oh i i bet
every cent i've ever made it was a team
based game i didn't lose
we lost that's true you did contribute
to the loss mark
yeah but it's my money and it's your
kneecaps
yeah isn't it against like major league
falls guy knockout rules to bet on games
this is
esports all right i i'll i'll do one
more just because that was really
pathetic
and um i actually called up the the
office
of bets the bet department and they said
they'll
they'll let me because that was really
that was really pathetic all right my
kneecaps
have one more chance also my shorts have
ridden up to the point where i feel like
i'm wearing a thong i need to fix my
shorts there we go
excellent all right this is going to be
the one right way
this is it victory i taste it i taste it
too
i feel it i feel it too creaming down
the nip mountain
i cream it too front and center front
center baby
back oh who's grabbing me oh god
oh i should have been committed oh my
god oh my god i was apparently on the
good side
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
it's such a fight through the doors
open the door is a victory for me why
are you not
changing your trajectory wade uh
yeah oh hey stop grabbing me
oh okay oh man it's getting chunky
oh my god no no get up get up get up get
up
okay we're all here together in this
yeah bad crowd of [ __ ]
go team go team i just uh got booty
bumps right into the oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh
[Applause]
i am so sorry for the things i've done
what have i done to deserve this oh my
god no
you ninja pieces [ __ ] okay it's fine
it's fine
are you guys still doing all right yeah
we're fine kind of we're going to you
pigeon dumb
[ __ ] oh god damn it all good in this
neighborhood my dude
live for me my friend we will live for
you i am currently alive
for you i am pleased with your god
oh my god that was that was definitely
wade's fault
i i leave space between me and the
person in front of me but not behind
no hell no whatever happens behind me is
their fault fair enough
okay mark you got this just don't be an
idiot no i would never
mark that was stupid oh no it wasn't it
was
go
all right we have a three and 15 chance
of pulling victory out wow
no we don't are we all dead i probably
didn't oh i
i thought you made it oh no a pigeon
slapped me into the abyss
oh i'm sorry well we have a two and
fifteen oh it's here all right wade
this is all you baby oh this is it this
is gonna be that front
you're in the back center that's my back
right i'm in the worst position
you got this way you got this yeah
i feel like this is fair to exist
there's a i have a fair chance of
winning
go mark i am go oh good i got [ __ ] by
a pigeon dude
you can do it i'm already doing it i'm
already doing it
yes you are oh my god oh my god oh my
god
oh my god oh my god so much anymore oh
my god uh yeah this
went a little off kilter but that's okay
is that you and wade on each other yeah
yeah i'm gonna grab this guy
just let the ninja mark what looks
correct
look you oh you you're mr outman
me mister wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
i've got a phone call yeah
no i i no i mean maybe i can get another
chance
please i don't want to have to steal my
friend's kneecaps
his elbows too no please
they're not good anymore his knees are
bad please
his teeth too all of his outer
appendages
well you'll forgive my you'll forgive my
debt you'll forgive my debt you'll
forgive my debt
you'll forgive my debt
okay all right wait i think you might
you should move on does mark know where
you live has he been to your house
you know everything's good man hey can i
i miss you i i miss you so much
i want to come see you like immediately
against my better judgment i'm willing
to accept this all right cool
just meet me halfway okay meet me
halfway
like in the middle of the desert
preferably no deserts in ohio preferably
like
nevada and just let's just
meet like on a farm even better a
secluded farm in the middle of the woods
hey that's great
middle of the woods what kind of farm
what are they growing there
woods trees all right cool i'll see you
soon man listen
i need you to keep this hush hush
between wade and i
he doesn't know the truth he doesn't
suspect a thing
but we know we know what to do
with the people that disappoint us we
won't let them do it again
and if a debt can be forgiven and all it
needs is a few
kneecaps
what's a few toes between friends
[Music]
foreign